I'm going to give you some inside code
here when a studio releases a Paranormal
Activity movie in January that is studio
code four we think this movie sucks ass
seriously they don't have faith in it it
shows in the release date
paranormal activity the marked ones so
Paranormal Activity the marked ones is
the fifth Paranormal Activity movie in
the Paranormal Activity franchise but
it's not actually Paranormal Activity
five I've heard Paranormal Activity five
is actually coming but this isn't it
this is like when you have a game
franchise it has a lot of installments
and then they have that storyline that
does tie in with the other ones that
comes out for the portable systems
that's the marked ones and in the marked
ones is one dude he's 18 years old of
course his friend gets a camera in this
creepy witch lady who lives in their
apartment complex dies and the weird
things start happening to this 18 year
old dude you guessed it at demons like
latching on to him otherwise known as
coolest demon friend ever this demon
gives this kid's superpowers he catches
up if he falls II please Simon with him
you know Simon boo boo boobs like a my
buddy doll in the form of something
ethereal and evil but you guessed it
this thing is evil this kid is in some
dire need of John Constantine but
Constantine's not around so this gets
pretty much screwed so is this franchise
really I have a litmus test to see if
movies like this are actually good after
the movie is over if I can go right to
my car at midnight in the pitch-black
drive home get into my house in pitch
black go right to my room with no
problem whatsoever this movie's pretty
much failed in its job to creep me out
and the reason is the Paranormal
Activity franchise is not what it used
to be it's not what it was when it
started I mean everyone in this movie
looks like they're phoning it in
Paranormal Activity one had this
charming simplicity to it took place
mostly in the bedrooms with violating
our safe space the bedroom to our DNA
that creeped us all out I felt like they
were trying to make this movie cool an
action film rather than actually scary
and creepy
oh yeah jump scares galore also are you
kidding me there a couple times this one
dudes walking up to this curtain he's
like hey man bro are you in there can
you hear me I was like he's gonna jump
out in 3 2 1
bottom jumps out I was like of course he
jumped out another time he goes into a
bathroom dead and he's like Oh literally
in my head was like turn around he
turned around a big creeps there and I'm
like various of course how else would
you construct this movie you feel like
Paranormal Activity the marked ones it's
like that little kid in the cul de sac
that comes up to you and all your
friends when you're playing baseball
they say hey can I plane you just want
to be like yeah let them play wants to
be with it you don't have any friends
you want to Pat this movie on the head
be like nice try and then in the end of
this movie tries to do something to make
it relevant but it really just can
sinks the entire franchise this is the
classic case of trying to make something
so big the entire franchise loses
perspective I'm gonna reference Star
Wars for a second I prefer Darth Vader
wipes out the Emperor because he was a
dad who didn't like to see his kid
getting fried no the prequels had to
come along and make it a big prophecy
some convoluted [ __ ] that made it so
big it wasn't relatable anymore and I
just didn't like it that's what this
movie is it tries to be so big and it
tries to bring everything into relevance
now by the end of this movie you're like
even the first one sucks now in the end
in the marked ones I was bored out of my
mind some things looked pretty cool yeah
there is one cool scene that creeped me
out all the lights go out and it was
ultimately it has to do with the audio
all the lights went out in the movie all
the speakers kicked on you felt like all
this creepy ass ambient noise was in the
theater good job sound guys the rest of
the movie can eat [ __ ] and die I'm not
looking forward to paranormal activity
any more I really enjoyed the first one
for what it did is almost a tradition at
this point but you know I wouldn't give
this movie this rating if I truly didn't
think it deserved it Paranormal Activity
the marked ones is [ __ ]
so Paranormal Activity the marked ones
have you seen what did you think about
it how about this I will say it for you
save you the time the Paranormal
Activity franchise does need to end I
got your back but whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you